pour nous et la coriandre là au début
dans l'accord il fonctionne très bien
pour les plantes les racines coup face
et apprendre à cultiver des bonzaïs aux
personnes âgées dans la résidence
fourcassa c'est une des occupations
proposé aux côtés notamment de la
cuisine ou d'ateliers web d initiative
accueillie positivement par les
résidents vous voyez j'ai moi même des
petits bonsaï que j'avais eue par
monsieur webb kullas mais ils sont donc
2 est à comparer aux 6 ans non mais
c'est très intéressant c'est bien ça
fait trois ans que je suis là youtube
vient ici l'autonomie est la règle les
seniors disposent d'une certaine liberté
ils organisent leurs programmes comme
ils l'entendent mais quelques services
obligatoires leur sont tout de même
fourni le fait qu'on soit résidence
autonomie fait que l'on doit proposer
des prestations obligatoires
c'est à dire que ça permet aux gens
d'être
alors passez aux surveillances mais
disons qu'elles sont dans un milieu
sécurisé et 24 heures sur 24
y compris donc les week-ends la
résidence phocas a évolué depuis 1978
aujourd'hui les personnes âgées ont leur
propre appartement
la ménage à leur convenance les
résidents peuvent recevoir leurs proches
j'ai ma chance et on fait ici la partie
là-bas ce sont ces la partie en cuisine
sachant que nous est ici dans des
enfants dans un appartement au moins je
ne cuisine pas l'établissement est géré
par l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
il accueille soixante trois personnes
âgées de plus de 60 ans